we saw over the United States obviously
the United States last week it's part of
Qatar where China but also Russia are
increasing their intelligence and
surveillance activities against NATO
allies with many different platforms we
see it in cyber and we see it with
satellites more and more satellites and
we see it and with balloons that
highlights the importance of our
vigilance our increased presence
and also that we ramp up and step up uh
how we share intelligence and how we
Monitor and protect our airspace and
actually one of the issues we're going
to address and decide on the on the
ministerial meeting tomorrow is
increased
um cooperation between allies in space